when you're looking up at a beautiful
dark night sky
what goes through my mind is the wonder
of it
it's just so incredibly vast
i never lose interest in it because it's
just so beautiful
i wanted others to enjoy the night sky
as much as they could
the best way to do that is to build your
own planetarium
the kovac planetarium is located in the
northwest of wisconsin in a little town
of monaco
i began the project in 1997 and it was
finally open to the public in 2007
i started from scratch
a lot of trial and error i had no
blueprints
there were many many times where i had
so many roadblocks come my way that i
wanted to give up
i just had to convince myself and my
neighbors that i wasn't crazy
and of course when i started putting up
this planetarium that was when people
really started to wonder about me
so it's kind of
neat i built this thing and now i get to
maintain it
keep it running for the shows
this is the largest mechanically
operated planetarium in the world
all the stars are hand-painted one dot
at a time
with glow-in-the-dark luminous paint
it took about five months this is the
only planetarium in the whole world that
has the night sky as glow-in-the-dark
paint
this is beyond normal but some of us
actually put
our dream into reality and do it
i took ordinary materials and i made
something extraordinary out of them